a picture of boris johnson on a screen
taking part in what it says was a
christmas quiz and also quoting a source
an anonymous source saying that downing
street staff were gathered around
computers taking part in this
whilst london was in tier 2 restrictions
and were drinking alcohol late into the
night
as well now downing street has put out a
statement in response to this in which
it said this was a virtual quiz downing
street staff were often required to be
in the office to work on the pandemic
response so those who are in the office
for work may have attended virtually
from their desks the prime minister
briefly took part virtually in a quiz to
thank staff for their hard work
throughout the year it is raising
questions though i think about those
flat-out denials that number 10 and
boris johnson issued around rule
breaking and parties this time last year
and how much he knew about it
and the labour leader
sakirshama is once again going on the
attack
well it's very serious um because it's
three days before the downing street
party that we've all been talking about
so it's very very serious
serious because the prime minister's
lost the authority to lead he's so weak
his party is so divided he can't provide
the leadership we need
at this crucial time he's he's the worst
possible leader at the worst possible
time
now in terms of how significant and how
damaging this photograph published by
the sunday mirror is clearly the um
accusations the allegations made of
people huddling around computers and
drinking alcohol mixing socially in a
work setting that would be of been
against um the law i think it adds to
a picture
and paints a narrative of what was going
on in number 10
last year when set against other
accusations and allegations
of other gatherings that were happening
around that time it cast doubt on the
flat out denial
and the uh tone that the prime minister
has adopted in response to previous
allegations of saying that he was
unaware of what was going on this
suggests that he might have had more of
an idea about the sort of thing that was
going on on that specific photo though
and this was
essentially what the defense from nadeem
zahawi was this morning the photo in
itself
may not be
as damaging as some of the other
accusations yes he has sat around a
table with two aides wearing christmas
decorations and you could say
that that represented
mixing that was against the rules
but what it does not show and it is not
as damaging as some feared i think it
doesn't show the prime minister
in a face-to-face situation in a packed
room so um i don't think it is
necessarily as bad as it could be but in
a week where he's facing a tight vote in
the commons and potentially a tight
by-election uh it was that it would be
the last thing the number 10 want
because it does put boris johnson's face
on this